est-ce que c'est définitivement qu on
reverra plus de chez ardisson sur le
groupe canal ou et ses clés de l'annonce
pour faire monter les enchères ses
cuisses et clank et voilà c'est que leur
vol paris libéré est ce qu est que
récupère la case en tant qu'animateur ou
deux c'est pas possible
voilà une petite question vous le saviez
depuis quand qu'il allait partir est ce
qui vous a appelés pour vous parler m'a
appelé il m'a appelé il m'a appelé on
est élu on est jolie on est en contact
avec thierry de ces dix derniers jours
j'ai lu tous les jours au téléphone
et sachez le et je le dis et thierry je
pense pour a confirmé j'ai tout fait
pour que thierry reste j'ai même proposé
jolie de le prendre sur mon contrat
voilà et de métro thierry sur mon
contrat pour le produire moi et qu'on
fasse une coproduction ensemble pour
trouver des moyens qui produisent moins
cher et voilages et on l'a tous proposés
mais thierry a été très clean puisque
c'est vrai qu'il y la région gillardin
associés dont vous pouvez pas voilà il
m'a dit vache a conduit déjà quelqu'un
je lui dis on peut peut-être essayer de
l'intégrer dedans mais on n'a pas trouvé
les moyens pour produire voilà avec moi
mais voilà j'ai tout fait jusqu'au bout
pour que thierry reste malheureusement
voilà ça c'est ça s'est pas fait et je
suis très très